3m you may recognize their work but the
company's real value is in the glue
where that makes those tiny paper stick
you get up in the morning and you start
your day and you wonder oh how many
three I'm products so I think I'll touch
today and my answer would be more than
you can count
three M's bottom line is all about
adhesives and they've got that market
cornered in the consumer world with our
post-its you can see it because it's the
product you buy many of the products
that we produce are used in a larger of
different devices where our product is
embedded in a final product so you don't
know it's necessarily in there the
chemicals that make stuff stick are not
new but the technologies they go into
are and that's what's keeping these guys
in business in order to create 55,000
plus products you need one heck of a
pool of Technology and capabilities
they're our second biggest lab
electronics and energy
you know those wires that you don't see
but make your daily life possible
thorium makes those materials and those
materials must be tested to their limits
this lab is our high voltage test lab
after we create new products we bring
them in here and we test them until they
blow up this transformer behind me that
is a two hundred and fifty thousand volt
AC noise-free transformer every year 3m
test about two hundred products a
lightning lab may seem like a far cry
from post-its but it's all a part of
this company's plan to dominate every
market touching every company every home
in every life overly ambitious one might
ask are you expanding to too many points
to reach we have to be brought we have
to be diversified the future's bright I
believe because that we have the
intention of broadening the things that
we do and broadening our technology